رغم فوز المنتخب والفرحه العار مكان في
لحظه مشاهدينا مرعبه في المباراه وصار في
قلق من بعدها احنا بنتكلم تحديدا عن لحظه
اصابه اللاعب ياسر الشهراني بعد تصادم قوي
خلال فرصه في المباراه لمنتخب الارجنتين
فعليا ياسر عمل كل جهده عشان الكره ما
تدخل ياسر وقع في الملعب وتوقف اللعب
دقائق وطلع وما قدر يكمل المباراه وكان في
قلق على حالته الا صحيه وتساؤلات عن
اصابته وكل هذا جاوب على المنتخب في بيان
رسمي ياكد في انه حاله ياسر الحمد لله
مستقره الان واصابته في الراس والصدر
والبطن وعمل كل الفحوصات في مدينه حمد
الطبيه وهو الان تحت الملاحظه واكد البيان
انه رئيس مجلس الاتحاد السعودي كان متواجد
وقت الفحوصات واستمع لتفاصيل حاله
الشهراني من الاطباء وكان موجود ايضا امين
عام الاتحاد وطاقم المنتخب الطبي من وقت
المباراه
ياسر الشهراني تراند وياسر الشهراني بنفسه
وبعدها
ظهر في مقطع فيديو من سرير المستشفى
وطمائن الجمهور عليه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
دعواتكم لي ومبروك الفوز جمهور السعودي
تستاهلون
والله يسهل الامور ان شاء الله في الايام
ان شاء الله شكرا لكم
وفي اخر بيان كمان للمنتخب تم الاعلان انه
ياسر الشهراني وصل مستشفى الحرس الوطني في
الرياض وسيجري عمليه جراحيه خلال الساعات
المقبله طبعا نحن تمنياتنا لياسر بالشفاء
التام والعاجل وحساب فيفا الرسمي على
تويتر حتى ايضا عبر عن مشاعره تجاه ياسر
وتمنى له العوده سريعا من هذه الوعكه
الصحيه وقال له ننتظر عودتك كلنا ننتظر
عودتك يا ياسر